it's okay not to be okay that's a
perfect song for this story
only on cbs this morning very nice stacy
we're taking you inside a pioneering
program
to help healthcare workers on the front
lines of the pandemic
build resilience now this may hold
lessons for all of us
we spoke with nurse managers at new york
city's mount sinai hospital about how
they say
the program has helped them heal our
senior medical correspondent that's dr
tarana rule she's here at the table in
person we get so excited
to take a look at the science of
resilience and why experts say
we should all be hopeful about the
future terri remember when you did the
first story about how medical workers
were struggling
it never occurred to me about the burden
that they were facing this was early on
i know so important it still continues
so this is such an important story
for those of us who've ever wondered if
we really have what it takes to bounce
back from difficult times in our lives
experts i spoke with say the proof is in
the science
i sat down with three nurse managers
from mount sinai here in new york
who just completed a resilience workshop
they say
has transformed their lives
summer is here marking a new beginning
for benson cahill
jenny drexler and chimina karena all
three are nurse managers at mount sinai
in new york
was there anything in your past that
prepared you for what you faced with
kovit this past year
i have been a nurse since 2005
2020 i would say was the most difficult
in my entire nursing career
a few years ago if you told me that i
would be doing this i would say
there's no way that would happen you
just fight and do what you have to do to
survive
we told them after over a year on the
front lines they've just completed
a five-week long resilience workshop
it's the first of its kind created
specifically for healthcare workers
fighting the war on kovid
you all obviously went into a field
where your entire focus
is on taking care of someone else sounds
like
from this workshop many of you learned
how to take care of yourselves
we learned a lot of coping skills look
at the good in every situation
live in the moment which is something
that i struggle with every day
we're fighting this virus it's a fight
we saw what was happening we needed to
respond
urgently to take care of our health care
workers
dr dennis charney has studied pows navy
seals and victims of trauma for decades
this is where the interaction is at the
height of the pandemic he created the
center for resilience at mount sinai
the brain is what we call plastic the
more you use it
the better it functions the brain
actually changes for the better
when you work at things like becoming
more resilient
what have you seen in the imaging
studies that you've done there seems to
be a more enhanced relationship between
the emotion parts of the brain
and the cognition parts of the brain
they seem to work better in concert when
you're under stress
for a lot of people they think
resilience is sort of psycho
mumbo jumbo babel but what you're saying
is there's actual
science there where you're changing the
neurochemistry and the functioning of
the brain
that's right but how do we train our
brains to become more resilient
practice says charney you're training
yourself in all aspects of your life
so when you face another trauma you say
i'm equipped and the key equipment says
charney is accessible to us all
building strong connections creating a
sense of purpose
and an optimistic outlook are all
characteristics of resilient people
we've heard it called a toolbox or a
tool kit
i call it a psychological toolbox and
you can pull out the elements that you
need
when you face the next challenge that's
right and we've seen that over and over
again
when you look back do you believe that
what you went through
will prepare you now for challenges that
are to come in the future
bring it on absolutely you never think
you're strong until you go through it
and get through it
and you look back and you realize how
far you've come
dr charney hopes their program can also
be applied on a larger scale
beyond the hospital setting into
communities that have been deeply
affected by covet 19
and the events of the past year
fascinating tara i think we could all
use a resilience workshop thank you for
that